thank you much thanks for having me
happy to be here so just for the context
of the talk so the other program which
is happening the semester the Institute
algorithm is an uncertainty a major
theme in that program is a circle of
ideas that I like to call beyond
worst-case analysis so for problems
computational problems where worst-case
analysis essentially gives you bad
advice about how to solve it it's a
quest for alternatives to analyze
algorithms which give you more accurate
advice about about what algorithm you
should use so this talk is sort of
squarely in that theme sort of try and
understand alternatives to worst-case
analysis especially ones that draw at
least somewhat on distributional
assumptions so let me just begin I'll
tell you a little bit what I mean by
worst-case analysis why you might want
alternatives what that alternatives
might be and then for most of the talk
I'll use a simple problem an auction
design to illustrate a bunch of
interpolations between worst and average
case analysis that have been sort of
useful for proving nice results and
obviously jump in with questions at any
time
I picked up the wrong one there we go
okay exactly
but mid-course correction so worst-case
analysis what do I mean okay so imagine
we've settled on a computational problem
and we settled on some performance
measure for algorithms like the running
time or like the quality of the solution
produced or like whether or not it's
correct
well worst-case analysis means it's just
you take the entire performance profile
of an algorithm ranging over all inputs
and as a summary statistic you look at
the one number of what's the worst that
the algorithm ever does on some input
maybe say parameterize by the input size
and you know we all know why worst-case
analysis is so popular so like what do I
tell my undergrads in the out in the
undergrad algorithms course well I say
you know what's great about worst-case
analysis is whenever you can prove a
positive result it's sort of great okay
it really means you don't even have to
have any model of data you don't have to
worry about what input shows up you just
run your algorithm it's gonna do great
everybody goes home happy and moreover
you know perhaps surprisingly there's
actually a lot of problems where
worst-case analysis gives you great
advice naturally leads you to exactly
the problems but the algorithms you
would want to use to solve those
problems in practice undergraduate
algorithms is chock-full of those kinds
of killer applications but you know as
you all know there's also perils to
worst-case analysis so principally you
know it can be overly pessimistic and so
one extreme example of this would be say
the running time of the simplex method
for linear programming which is famously
theoretically exponential in the worst
case even though you never ever see
running times anywhere close to
exponential on real linear programs and
then also you know I sort of mentioned
not having a data model as being a good
thing of worst-case analysis but it cuts
both ways right so yeah the patent you
don't have a data model actually you
sort of have a data model which I would
call the Murphy's Law data model it's a
Murphy's Law says whatever can go wrong
will go wrong so worst case analysis is
basically saying I assume that the input
which is relevant from my application
depends on which algorithm I pick which
is a sort of kind of paranoid and
slightly incoherent way that to think
about the world basically so what would
be an alternative well there's another
way of analyzing algorithms it shows up
in undergrad classes average case
analysis so how would this work well you
posit some distribution over the
and you just want to optimize the
expected performance of the algorithm
the expectation with respect to that
input distribution and this is also you
know super useful and actually more and
more these days as the amount of
available data gets getting bigger and
bigger if you have a problem you have a
really good understanding of the input
distribution and that understanding is
not too volatile and you don't need a
general-purpose solution by all means
you know use the algorithm which is best
on average on the other hand the concern
is that you know that the algorithm you
wind up deriving is an artifact of the
specifics of your input distribution so
the worry is that you come up with a
solution which is fine for one
distribution but it's not robust if
you're a little bit wrong on the
distribution where the distribution
changes on you maybe the algorithm will
be even near optimal anymore okay so
those are some of the standard concerns
with average case analysis so a major
theme in the other semester a big part
of the ah worst case analysis is what I
like to call hybrid models so these are
interpret these are trying to take the
best of both worlds from the worst-case
world and from the average case world
and so what's been emerging what's in
clear is that for lots of problems
there's a sweet spot for analyzing
algorithms of this sort of a hybrid
model so if in the worst case you look
at the worst input and the average case
you average over inputs and a hybrid
model what you do is rather than
committing to just one input
distribution you say well let me just
make some very coarse assumptions about
what the input distribution looks like
I'm not gonna assume it's uniform or
exponential or normal anything like that
I'll just assume maybe independence or
sort of some control over the tails this
kind of thing
so I have in mind a whole big set of
input distributions and I have no idea
which one is the real one and then what
you'd like is you like an algorithm that
no matter what the input distribution is
in the set you do well on average with
respect to that distribution okay so you
take a worst-case over what the input
distribution might be and then you take
average case with respect to any
particular distribution okay thinking of
it differently you want an algorithm
which is sort of simultaneously near
optimal for lots of distributions all at
once
okay so there's a lot of stuff you could
say about about these hybrid models the
whole second half of my bootcamp
tutorial was all about all about
examples of these so you know why do I
like them well so the you know
when it works out you inherit the
robustness from the worst-case world
basically because the algorithm has to
be good for many many different input
distributions it can't be overly
tailored to any one of them and then
also actually when you solve for the
best algorithm of this type the theory's
tends to naturally lead you the kind of
very practical algorithms things you
could actually imagine implementing and
a worst-case analysis that that's true
sometimes and not true sometimes and
there's famous examples of these hybrid
models which you've heard which I'm not
going to talk about but smooth analysis
you know by Spielman and ten can be
thought of as a hybrid model where
basically the distribution just has sort
of sufficient entropy in it and semi
random models also and then random order
models like say secretary problems if
you're familiar with those those all
sort of fall under the umbrella of
hybrid models okay those aren't the ones
going to talk about today there's many
examples so what I want to talk about
today is I want to talk about a simple
problem in option design okay
so I'm gonna use options as sort of a
scaffolding to talk about lots of
different ways of doing performance
analysis okay because it's convenient
but all of the ideas we'll talk about
are relevant brought in a broad
algorithmic context not just about
options okay so what sort of performance
measure of options might you want to
optimize okay well if you're selling
stuff you might want to maximize revenue
okay and even if you just sell something
on eBay there's sort of a decision you
have to make which affects the revenue
that you make okay so here's what an
eBay auction looks like so you advertise
an item people bid on it and you don't
have any things you can choose and
anybody option almost everything is
determined for you but one knob that you
do have is the opening bid okay
so the opening bid says don't even
bother bidding unless it's at least this
number okay and you can set it to be
zero totally allowed or you could set it
to be really large eight thousand okay
and the question is how should you set a
reserve price when you put something up
on eBay okay as far as how the rest of
you day works if you haven't seen it
before it's equivalent to what's called
the second price auction so basically
when you bid on eBay
the eBay will bid on your behalf just
high enough to beat out all the
competition if you're actually the
highest bidder so one thing to realize
is that why is it a second price auction
whatever you bid in eBay in general if
you win you
to pay the full amount that you bid you
only have to pay the minimum amount
needed to beat everybody else that's why
it's a second-price auction you only pay
the second highest bidder overall okay
and these opening bids are often called
reserve prices in auction theory this so
this is not Photoshop I'm trying to
remember the Google search that led me
to this I think I'd like googled
ridiculous eBay auctions and this is
what I got I mean to add to add to the
credibility of it I will point you to
maybe someone's really hungry yeah so
how should you set this opening bid well
this is this actually it's already a
super simple problem it's not that easy
to reason about right if there's a
sucker willing to pay $1,000 this looks
like a great reserve price okay if there
isn't this looks like a really stupid
reserve price but of course you don't
know what people are willing to pay
that's why you're running the auction in
the first place okay so how should you
think about this and you know for people
who think about algorithms this is not a
new problem right so like any two
algorithms one's going to be better on
some inputs the other on other inputs
and we still have lots of ways of kind
of comparing algorithms and reasoning
about algorithms and again the first one
that you try in the computer science
world is worst case analysis so let me
just point out how for this problem how
do you set an opening bid problem worst
case analysis is a total non-starter
okay nothing interesting is possible
using sort of straightforward worst-case
analysis on this on this very simple
problem so to do this I need a model so
single item auctions for this well we'll
be thinking about all talk is this
simple setup so it's just it's really
just sort of you know the eBay set up
your one seller one item some number n
of bidders and valuation that just means
the maximum willingness to pay okay so
bitter eye is willing to pay up to VI
dollars at most for this item and
importantly only the bidder is know
these V odds as a seller you don't know
what these are
okay that's why you're running the
auction okay and what you'd like to do
is make as much money as possible all
right so what would worst-case analysis
said it would say well you know we have
this set of feasible solution
all the different opening bids we could
set and input by input ie no matter what
bidders valuations are we would like to
make close to the revenue we could get
with the best of the feasible solutions
with the best opening bid ok so to see
the problem suppose only one bidder
shows up ok that's not necessary for the
bad example but it makes it simple
suppose one bidder shows up and they
have some willingness to pay v ok and
you know maybe it's you know something
like seven thousand nine hundred ninety
nine dollars maybe that's their
valuation alright now there is an
opening bid
if you chose it that would give you
seven thousand nine hundred ninety nine
dollars right if you said that as the
reserve as the opening bid you would
make this full V dot of money I think
maybe you set the reserve to be V minus
Epsilon okay but if you sort of telepath
we knew what their willingness to pay
was you could extract all of that as
revenue by just setting the opening bid
to the valuation of course you know but
if you set eight thousand instead you're
going to make nothing okay the second
person has much lower valuation then you
only get that much so right so the way
you Bay works is you pay the minim the
maximum of the reserve or the second
highest bid so it's kind of only good
for the seller if the reserve is in the
sort of the good case for the seller
with the reserve is you split the first
and second highest bidders that's where
it gives you a payoff yeah of course the
risk is if you overshoot everybody you
lose everything okay but nothing deep
here I'm just pointing out that you know
if you thought about like what would be
the most rate full way of applying
worst-case analysis to the problem of
choosing the suitable opening bid it
tells you nothing
it doesn't every algorithm has no
guarantee at all there's literally
nothing to prove okay a formal sense so
clearly we do need some alternative all
right if we want to sort of reason about
different auctions so you know auctions
have been for a long around for a long
time I mean probably like economists
have been payment options forever right
yeah they have so what do they do
they've made progress on this problem
well the dominant paradigm in economics
is what we would call average case
analysis so they would call it Bayesian
analysis so we're gonna make a
distributional
assumption we're going to assume that
bitter eyes willingness to pay is drawn
from a distribution F sub I I'll always
be thinking of the valuations being as
being independent will go back and forth
between whether they're identical or not
okay so both cases are interesting all
right so as the seller the assumption is
you know or you have in mind these
distributions f1 through FN okay so you
know how the valuations are distributed
you do not still know the realization so
you do not know the V eyes that would
trivialize the problem but you do know
the F eyes okay
so now we have a distribution of our
inputs right so just bids drawn from
these distributions and now we have a
well-defined optimization problem we can
save all the auctions in the world find
the one that makes the highest amount of
expected revenue where the expectation
is with respect to this distribution
okay there's a well posed mathematical
problem there's going to be some option
which is better than any othe other with
respect to some fixed distribution and
it's natural to ask what it is okay so
all right so I talked about all the
auctions in the world and we're not
going to you know I'm going to
deliberately just stick with very simple
options throughout this talk because I
know some of you have sort of probably
never thought about auctions so go ahead
and think about eBay as a canonical
example second price auction with a
reserve but in general you know the
optimal auction can be pretty crazy okay
all that you know it just has to have
some way of giving the bids figuring out
who wins and forgetting out what the
winner if there is one is going to pay
okay so the auction design space is very
rich that we're going to focus our
attention on simple points in that
design space okay so this is the
standard economic setup and indeed in
economics this problem was totally
solved completely solved by Meyerson
about 35 years ago okay what do I mean
solved a madison gives a closed-form
solution for what the optimal auction is
as a function of the distributions okay
and just I mean to be clear notice that
you know the OP what the optimal auction
is is going to depend on what the
distribution is right so for example if
you're using a reserve price clearly if
the distributions are sort of on just
have small valuations you'll use a small
reserve price but if the distributions
just have lots of high valuations you'd
expect to use a high reserve price okay
so there is going to be some dependence
on what the optimal option is on what
distributions you is
okay but Meyerson stalls for the entire
mapping
he just says tell me what your
distributions are I'll tell you what the
optimal auction is so it's a great
result I mean this is one of the results
for which Meyerson got the Nobel Prize
and I think was over seven okay and in
the symmetric case when I say symmetric
I mean iid hey so imagine all bidders
valuations are distributed identically
then actually the optimal auction is
just eBay which is kind of amazing
because again the auction design space
is really rich has all these very
strange creatures in it we optimize over
this whole big space and we get back a
super practical and the already widely
used option second price auction with a
reserve so there is still going to be
some dependence of this auction on the
distributional assumption but it will
only be through this reserve price so
depending on what the valuation
distribution is you'll use different
reserve prices but actually even the
reserve price itself has a super simple
intuition it's what's called the
monopoly price of a distribution that
just means what take-it-or-leave-it
offer when you give somebody drawn from
a distribution to maximize your expected
revenue yes if the distributions given
by F you just say okay well which price
would maximize my expected revenue so
this is the revenue of the sale this is
the probability of a sale which every P
makes us as big as possible that's
called the monopoly price in particular
and people often find this
counterintuitive the best reserve price
to use does not depend on the number of
bidders it's independent of n you always
just want to use the monopoly price for
the distribution okay so this is just a
you know magical confluence of theory
and practice right we solve over this
huge space the optimal point of
something totally totally can just put
to use right away the general case while
Marsha did solve it so we sort of know
what the answer is you don't get
anything resembling something this
simple or you really you don't get
anything resembling any auctions which
are actually deployed in the real world
okay
so in general if bidders are not iid the
optimal option is complex and it depends
in a detailed way on the distributions
okay so here the dependence on the
distribution was just to compute this
one number here it's sort of a
complicated mapping of the entire
distributions
there's probability so this is the
probability that the person is willing
to pay at least P yeah so that's the
probability of sale at price P that's
the revenue of a sale at price P so
that's the expected yes yeah so like if
they were if they ever say exponential
distributions with different rates you
could say something sharper about what
it looks like so so what do we just do
we just did average case analysis so
we're finding so we have this problem
what's single item auction maximizes
revenue worst case analysis total
non-starter average case analysis
totally solved but we sort of you know
we're tempted to reject the at least in
the in the asymmetric case reject what
optimal auction theory advocates on the
basis of not resembling anything that
anybody uses and so this is an example
where the payrolls of average case
analysis is if you carry it through to
its logical conclusions you can wind up
advocating things which you can't
actually implement okay and that where
you also might be worried about
robustness and actually I mean this is
not you know economists know this too
it's not like we're the only ones who
know the perils of average case analysis
there's even something kind of cheekily
referred to as Wilson's doctrine after
Bob Wilson who's a famous auction
theorist and so he really was in a
basically a position paper talking about
how mech new action designs should
aspire toward solutions toward auctions
which do not depend in a detailed way on
knowledge assumptions okay like the
details of these valuation distributions
so this is this is sort of an old
critique in economics but it turns out
the computer science toolbox has a lot
of tools to make sort of new interesting
progress in this direction
okay so alternatives sort of more robust
versions of average case analysis from
which you actually get simpler and more
usable solutions any questions at that
point that's kind of the introduction
context yeah
the hybrid model definition reminds me
of the definition of minimax estimators
and then then there's a duality that
says minimax are bayesian with respect
to like particularly chosen least
informative priors and I'm wondering if
there's a connection yeah let's see I
mean I see the general as far as the
order quantifiers at if I see the
analogy with the minimax estimators know
logically when you when you find that
out these hybrid model solutions is it
the case that they are also the Bayes
optimal solutions for some particular
that's good that's a good question
generally not yeah so that's why the
duality part I wasn't so sure it didn't
sound like that matched up well so if
there's time at the end we'll actually
sort of insist that we only use
solutions which at least would be
optimal with respect to some
distribution that'll be the very final
part of the talk at this time yeah so
the I think the first part there is a
connection in the second part doesn't
seem like it other questions
so here's the plan so we're gonna keep
talking about this you know how should
you know what single item option should
be used to maximize revenue worst case
analysis fails average case analysis
kind of succeeds theoretically but
advocates complicated solutions so now
we're gonna look at outposts in between
okay we're gonna move from left to right
so we're to start from average case
analysis and successively weaken the
knowledge assumptions okay I'm going to
just highlight a couple results at each
of these outposts of what you can do
okay all right so the first idea is
alright let's just we're still gonna
have distributional assumptions but
they're gonna be more modest in some
sense okay so we're going to assume that
we only have partial knowledge about
what the input distribution actually is
and there's two notions of partial
knowledge I'm going to show you both I
think will be natural for this audience
one is suppose I just told you some
simple statistics of the distribution
okay like I told you it's mean or its
median something like that what would
you do and you know nothing else so
otherwise it's sort of a worst-case
distribution subject to conforming to
the statistics that you know and we'll
look at a sample model okay where you're
partial and all where knowledge is
parameterized by how many samples you
have from that distribution from an
unknown distribution okay so there's a
couple so the math remains the same but
there's sort of two different
interpretations of the math so the first
one you know it's the way I phrased it
so far is you just don't you really just
don't know or not confident about the
full distributional knowledge where
maybe you are pretty confident about
like the mean of a distribution okay
actually a second interpretation which
is even if you were fully confident in
these input distributions and so in
principle you could use the
theoretically optimal option again you
might reject this option you know is
theoretically optimal because it cannot
be deployed so a second thing that
byproduct of this approach is to in fact
you're assisting on simple options which
you know are robust with respect to many
distributions and therefore not as
complex as the as the optimal ones we
talked about before okay so I started
tart thinking about this with Jason Hart
line in 2009 or so and we're actually
motivated initially by the second
interpretation we said you know it may
be you know the distributions that's
fine but you know what do people use in
the real world people use reserve prices
so what if I go ahead and tell you the
full distributional knowledge but
force you to use a simple option in the
form of an auction that just uses
reserve prices what can you do so you
know once you're talking about reserved
prices you naturally gravitate toward
monopoly prices so another
interpretation of these results is you
know maybe the only thing you know about
a distribution is the monopoly price and
there's another interpretation of these
theorems now remember in the symmetric
case in the iid case what was the
optimal auction it was just a bay it was
a second price auction with a suitable
reserve so if I tell you the monopoly
price in a symmetric setting that is
already enough to know what the optimal
option is okay you know the monopoly
price you know the optimal auction now
the non-id case each bidder has their
own reserve price you might hope that if
you knew everybody's monopoly reserve
that would be enough to run the optimal
option in the non-id case but that is
not true okay optimal auctions again
need much more information than just the
monopoly price so if we're thinking
about asymmetric settings and we only
know monopoly prices we will lose
something okay compared to the
theoretically optimal auction and we
will not do as well because we're using
a more restricted auction class so the
goal then is to quantify how much do you
lose how far from this benchmark do you
get by focusing on reserve price based
auctions and ideally you'd like to be
you know as close to optimal as possible
so again I want to mention you know so
different distributions will have the
same monopoly prices and different
optimal options so in effect you can
think of this as a hybrid model where
the set of distributions is all of the
distributions that have the specified
monopoly prices and worst case over
distributions that would lead to these
monopoly prices that's how you evaluate
your auction
all right so what can you prove so
suppose I said wouldn't it be nice if
you could just use a monopoly price for
each bidder for their respective
distributions I want to be nice as that
was optimal we said no that's not
optimal optimal options are more complex
but you can't approve you can prove
approximation guarantees for exactly
that auction nice again to be clear what
are we doing we now have a different
reserve price per bidder or revisit this
in a second if this bothers you let's
say you have one reserved price for each
bidder the monopoly prices of their
respective distributions and then among
people who clear their reserve price you
doing a second price auction and again
the price that you pay is going to be
the maximum of your reserve price or the
highest other bid okay
and so that's going to get a constant
fraction of the optimal auction even for
worst-case distributions that conform to
those monopoly prices okay and in fact
you really have to lose the 50% in the
worst case so whatever our whatever
reserve price auction you decide to use
I can show you distributions where the
optimal option for those distributions
is twice as good as yours so you can
make stronger assumptions if you want to
make this 50 percent a bigger number but
without further assumptions this is the
right answer 50 percents the right hands
all right so I mean this is not a kind
of talk I'm gonna have time to really
discuss proofs at all but so let me just
say just sort of one thing which is you
know wow you know in in this theory we
sort of rejected optimal''option theory
these theoretically complex options you
know as far as something you might
actually design but I want to emphasize
the traditional economic theory is still
crucial and actually doing the analysis
of these simpler auctions so as far as
what is the proof looks like we use
exactly the same kind of analytical
tools which were developed by economists
to solve the optimal auction theory
problem I mean one things it is they're
given their valuation from the sky
independently yeah so yeah so it's one
shot yeah yeah and in fact you know the
auctions I'm talking about there's no
need to strategize so an eBay
you know modulo timing effects there's
no need to strategize right so if you're
being charged the second highest bid it
doesn't help you to shade your bid you
can derive it from a profit inequality I
don't know if I call the generalization
but it's more like a consequence of the
profit inequality combined with
techniques from optimal auction theory
yeah
yeah that's a good point
just so if the bids were say like in
addition some range like wanted to be or
something like that
if you're willing to get up to do worse
to get like a the one over a log B
factor yep you could just pick like a
random you know Bryce according to
powers of two or something and then that
work in general yeah so if there's not
much of a like if you know up front that
the valuations are pretty tightly
concentrated then I mean the auction
design problem isn't that hard I guess
is a way is that a fair summary or I
guess a higher level you know I think
yeah if you have a pretty good sense of
where people's valuations lie it's not
actually clear you'd run an auction you
can just say buy it now it sort of you
know the midpoint of that interval or
something like that ranges yeah
reasonably high right so like you know
so and you know on eBay you know still
to this day you know kind of what it's
really used most heavily for is kind of
like collectible markets so like I'm a
record collector so sometimes I go on
there and buy records and stuff and
there you really do see big spreads and
what it goes for
like people sell one for a hundred bucks
and the next week one goes for 20 bucks
kind of thing so good question so
where's the computer science so what's
what so the only throughout everything
I'll say today it's really the sort of
culture and the toolbox of computer
science which is being applied so it's
not about computation and I think I'll
say anything today which has n handy
with computation exactly exactly and so
here's it's true or just a constant
fraction so just some relaxation so
being okay with being you know less than
100 percent of optimal especially when
optimal is something which is in an
option on the table anyways as is the
case here so for whatever reason I mean
this tradition of approximation is close
to unique for theoretical peer science
and I'm not sure why but in any case so
in economics it has not been part of the
mainstream at all instead what you do is
you look at kind of you know the
and a paradigm his more look at
sufficiently strong assumptions they can
get exactly what you want as opposed to
keep weak assumptions and get a sort of
relaxed conclusion so that's right so
somehow this is not a new concept in
they're not trying to shoot for the
optimum oh yeah so right so from the
individuals perspective it's a good
point yeah they're kind of used to that
relaxation it's somehow like the design
perspective you know you want to and
it's not always it's not as an
optimization problem sometimes you
specify properties and you want to
design which meets all these properties
but somehow you know reasonable
approximation as some kind of property
is has barely been studied a little bit
but it's really not part of the
mainstream so that's I mean and that
fact has allowed computer science to
make contributions here so to make
progress on this Wilson doctrine which
wasn't you know being done previously
yeah that's a good question
and that'll really be true for
everything else I say everything else I
say well we will be borrowing you know
MOT you know ways of thinking from
computer science but at no point well I
mentioned the word polynomial time or
np-hard or anything like that
next slide yeah yeah so the this is
before except everybody gets their own
reserve price so this is Dan's question
which is good good question so and and I
understand if you're uncomfortable this
like so you look at you look at this
auction where because remember different
people have different distributions so
different people have different monopoly
prices so when I say use monopoly
reserve prices I mean use a different
one for each bidder eBay for example
does not allow you to do that okay you
get one reserved price for everybody now
you do see better specific reserves in
practice although they usually sort of
disguised because sort of hide the
discriminatory aspect but like in
sponsored shirts you can use so-called
the quality scores to implement that I
mean they do use quality scores to
implement better specific reserves so
it's not it's not an impractical concept
but you might ask you know what if I
force you to use eBay and I force you to
to prove some resort to you some reserve
price and they're you know the constant
gets worse unfortunately too but still
you can do something so there is there
is an anonymous reserve price which no
matter what the distributions are not
non identical you get a constant
fraction
I mean again so so like with like with
all approximation results you need to be
clear-eyed about what it is you're
comparing to and when you're comparing
to something which is like hypothetical
and not an option you shouldn't be sad
right so like if you told me my baseball
team only won 65 percent of the games
out of the maximum possible I would be
very happy okay so there's no reason I
mean you can do this exercise with other
statistics not just monopoly prices so
is our macaulay and then later with das
glaucous and Weinberg they had some nice
results of this forum this is just for
single item options there's actually a
rich literature which looks at problems
more complex than single item options
and does the same kind of same kind of
theory okay alright so the other model
of parcel knowledge that when I mention
is samples so here you know it's just
very directly inspired by Pack style
models in learning theory so here the
idea is you don't really so what do you
know about the distribution you know a
bunch of I these samples from the
distribution okay you have to decide on
what auction to run using only those
samples and nothing else so you do not
directly know the distribution except
through samples about it right so then
you can ask sample complexity type
questions like how many samples ie how
much data is necessary and sufficient
before you can get a reasonable
simulation of what you could accomplish
with full distributional knowledge so
you'd like ideally your expected revenue
to be at least one minus epsilon times
what you could achieve with the optimal
auction we're the full knowledge okay so
that's sort of the strong benchmark to
use and you might want I think about
epsilon is you know 0.1 or 0.01 okay so
one like the 50% we just saw here we
really want to get quite close and the
question is how much data do we need to
actually do that and I should say I mean
you know this paradigm is actually used
in practice the idea where you look at
past bids you think of them as samples
from some distribution reverse-engineer
the distribution think about what
optimal auction theory would tell you
for those fitted distributions and then
use that to inform for example how you
set reserve prices on sponsored search
engines okay so it actually Maps pretty
closely to to how the search engines
actually do this
okay so this is just same when I said
again in cartoons so let me just mention
some results instead so again the
question we're asking alright there's an
unknown distribution you're getting s
samples based on the samples you pick an
auction you were hoping to pick an
option whose expected revenue is almost
as good as the optimal one for that
distribution so the question is as a
function of all of the relevant
parameters how many samples are
necessary and sufficient to achieve this
goal to get a 1 minus epsilon
approximation we expect it to be blowing
up with 1 over Epsilon
all right the better you want to
approximate an optimal the more samples
you presumably need it may or may not be
blowing up in the number of bidders and
the other parameter we have okay so in
the symmetric case it turns out the
dependence is there's no dependence on n
there's a dependence only on 1 over
Epsilon and you actually pin down
exactly what the exponent of 1 over
epsilon is for different classes of
distributions this shouldn't surprise
you if you remember way back at the
beginning we said the optimal auction in
the symmetric case actually is just a
second price auction with a monopoly
Reserve and the monopoly reserve is
independent of the number n of bidders
so that's in effect why morally you're
hoping that you're not going to have
dependence on in an ID case in the
general case you do have dependence both
on N and on 1 over epsilon it is
polynomial on both however ok and one
thing I just want to mention about the
lower bound right so this is both a
lower and upper bound the lower bound
says really if you don't use n samples
where n is the number of bidders then
you can't be near optimal what that
proof actually shows it kind of shows
the limitations of how far the Wilson
doctrine could go right so we talked
about optimal auctions we said they can
be really complex we said well you know
if you're willing to lose if you're
willing to have a course approximation
if you're willing to lose a factor too
then you actually don't need
distributional knowledge you just need
to know the reserve prices but but what
this proof really implies is that if you
want a 1 minus epsilon approximation for
sufficiently small epsilon you have no
choice but to use very detailed
distributional knowledge okay so really
yeah so this is proving that using
significantly simpler options than the
theoretically optimal ones requires a
significant degradation on the
approximation factor there's really
nothing you can do about it
all right some questions about that
section so let me talk a little bit
about unknown distributions and so to
show you what I mean let me show you a
sort of famous result from auction
theory known as the Bulow Klemperer
theorem and this is proven by a couple
economists but actually think it has a
very computer science e-flat
so it here's what you do so you think
about a single item auction like we've
been thinking about think about the
symmetric case bidders iid from this
distribution so the below clamp and n is
the number of bidders so Bulow klemper
they compare to things that compare the
revenue of the optimal option for this
distribution F so second price auction
with a monopoly reserved verse is the
revenue expected revenue of the second
price auction so Vickrey auction just
means second price auction with no
Reserve so the reserve price here is
zero the reserve price here is going to
be the monopoly price so Beulah clamper
estates an inequality between these two
quantities which seems kind of silly
right so this is an auction that's an
optimal auction so I guess there should
be an equality going this direction
right less more the Buick member
actually flip the inequality okay
what's the catch they give the second
price auction with no Reserve a slight
advantage in the form of one additional
bidder again with valuation drawn ID
from the same distribution F okay so if
you have to make a decision if so if you
if you have to you know choose between
spending resources to recruit one new
bidder to your auction or learning
everything about the preferences of your
bidders the first options always better
okay so that's usual interpretation
increasing the competition and an
auction is the is really the best way to
to improve your revenue and which i
think is actually pretty good advice in
a lot of cases so that's if you look
limper theorem so now on a technical
level here's what I want to call your
attention to on the left hand side we
have a second-price auction with no
Reserve price so the left hand side is
independent of the distribution of the
valuation distribution F hey whatever F
is this is just second price auction
with no Reserve but as I vary F this
right hand side I'm using different
auctions
okay so have one auction on the left
satisfying this guarantee for every
possible option on the right for every
choice of the distribution F okay so
that in this sense we have one option
which is simultaneously optimum or near
optimal with respect to a wide range of
distributions okay which is really kind
of the canonical version of the hybrid
model like I was talking about so this
notion of prior independent auctions
which is basically just trying to get
guarantees of this form okay so you
really want one auction who's no matter
what the distribution is the expected
revenue of your auction is almost as
good as the optimal for those
distributions it's going to one auction
simultaneously near optimal for lots of
distributions is the idea that result
that additional person's someone sets
the reserve yeah so not exactly monopoly
price but but basically what you get out
of this is an extra person setting a
random reserve is within a factor 2 of
the optimal reserve which is kind of
interesting right so yeah any quality
but how close do you get rid of to none
good question so if you can plan n minus
1 over n approximation so even with the
same number of bidders you can pair
something quite strong about how close
they are
ok so that's a prior independent auction
okay so you want to you want a close
approximation no matter what the
distribution is and I think an interest
some time I will skip so the point is
there is an auction fits on three lines
and you can do this ok so including for
very general problems actually so you
can get again you're losing a kind of
factor 2 which is you know related to
the factor 2 that we were talking about
before as well but you don't really lose
more than that from an unknown
distribution so again for comparison
remember what I told you I said suppose
I told you the distributions and not
force you to use reserve prices you're
already off by a factor 2 now I'm saying
you're not you don't even get to see the
distributions at all and so you lose the
factor 2 as before but then only sort of
a factor which is close to 1 okay the
idea of the mechanism is very simple and
actually completely related to what Dan
just said you basically take one bidder
and they're a sacrificial lamb okay you
pick a bitter at random there's no
chance they're gonna win you use their
bid to reserve price everybody else so
that's what makes this work so again
what's nice is you get this robust
guarantee but you can achieve it already
with a you know pretty reasonable
solution three line solution
so just briefly on this last topic so
again we've been moving from you know
the average case of world to the worst
case world but so far we've always had
distributions okay ultimately we've been
evaluating our auctions with respect to
some distribution the question was just
how much do we know about the
distribution now we're actually going to
recover a form of worst-case analysis
okay
so here we'll use distributions kind of
only in our minds as a thought
experiment and we'll actually get worst
case guarantees so these are called
prior free auctions so that last part
was called prior independent where you
assume a distribution here we're not
going to assume a distribution on inputs
we really want two input by input
guarantee so we want to say no matter
what bidders want we want our auctions
revenue to be within a constant factor
of the maximum possible hopefully for a
small constant alpha but if you remember
you should be thinking isn't this
exactly like the non-starter example
that we had being the talk to say why we
need alternatives and it is you'd be
right so depending on how you define the
benchmark how you define Optive V this
may or may not be possible to prove
theorems of this form and if you define
this just to be the highest the highest
willingness to pay of any bidder as we
saw there's no way to reason about the
problem there's no interesting
guarantees so and you know there's
actually one of the earliest
contributions by computer science to
revenue maximizing auctions was the idea
okay well I guess that we need to do is
be smarter about what we're comparing to
so we need a smarter revenue benchmark
alright and so this you know for those
of you that know about online learning
that's sort of a good analogy to have in
mind right an online learning the first
thing you'd think you want to do is have
an online algorithm that competes with
the best action sequence in hindsight's
there's a trivial example that shows
that's completely impossible
so you instead say okay let's change the
benchmark let's say that an online
algorithm is good if it merely competes
with the best fixed action in hindsight
so that's how changing the benchmark can
change a algorithm design problem from
uninteresting the interesting ok just by
getting the benchmark sort of the right
scale so Goldberg hardline and right and
right really thought hard about this
problem and they proposed revenue
benchmarks and proved some really nice
results of this form okay so they really
showed that prior free options can exist
for the appropriate benchmark
and you know for many years it was kind
of a dark art like where these
benchmarks came from like it wasn't
really you know you kind of just try to
find one which worked worked in the
sense you could prove positive results
and also prove kind of nearly matching
negative results and that you got
reasonable constants and so you know
together with Jason hard-line we tried
to think about you know is there a
systematic way of generating meaningful
revenue benchmarks like where did these
come from these revenue benchmarks and
there's a very tight connection between
the prior independent auctions that I
was just mentioning the last segment hey
this idea of being simultaneously near
optimal for range of distributions so
here's what you do
we're going to nearly as a thought
experiment pass to the average case
world okay we're not going to actually
assume the input comes from a
distribution we will not assume that but
just temporarily let's think in our
minds well
auction would we run if input was drawn
from a distribution let's say in the iid
case well we've gone over this right we
just run a second-price auction with a
suitable reserve and the reserve depends
on what the distribution is okay so
that's the result of the thought
experiment if we were Bayesian iid we do
a second-price auction with a suitable
reserve so here's the template for
defining the benchmark okay so now fix
an arbitrary valuation profile if who's
willing to pay out okay now restrict
yourself to auctions that you would use
if there was a distribution okay so this
is what came up earlier right now in
this case it's just second price
auctions with all possible reserves so
the definition of the benchmark on a
given valuation profile is how much
money could any second price auction
with a reserve price extract in this
particular input and that's the
definition of the benchmark okay so you
think about see the distributional
thought experiment think of everything
that might arise and then on a given
input you take the best of any of those
solutions to the distributional problem
and this is what you use as your
benchmark and this can be thought of as
sort of you know you you want to have
you want to talk about an ie D setting
but without a distribution and this
benchmark gives you a deterministic
proxy for doing exactly that and again
you think about no regret benchmarks as
being similar or you know in data
structures I think of static optimality
it's kind of a deterministic stand-in
for saying you
imagine queries were happening in an ID
fashion because then the optimal data
structure wouldn't back be static
alright so what should I say about this
so this template you know regenerates
the kind of revenue benchmarks that were
proposed earlier and you can also use it
to tackle more general problems I said I
wanted the benchmarks to not only be not
only to be sort of generated
automatically but also to automatically
be meaningful okay and this is always
the problem with a benchmark you're like
okay your algorithm gets close to this
benchmark is that good is that bad does
it say your algorithm is good or does it
say the benchmark is bad like how should
I think about it and so here's the sense
in which benchmarks that you generate in
this way are automatically meaningful if
you compete ie you approximate input by
input this benchmark then has an
automatic consequence you get the
simultaneous distributional guarantee
that we're talking about in the previous
segment in other words a prior free
auction is always a prior independent
auction it is only harder to design
prior free options and prior independent
options and this is pretty much
immediate from the definitions and so
basically if there was a distribution
you'd be using some optimal option on
every input and input by input you found
an auction which competes with every
single possible optimal auction and so
averaging you get the same guarantee
okay so that's the high-level takeaway
okay so why'd the benchmarks meaningful
well at the very least it implies the
prior independence guarantee but it's
even stronger than that okay so just a
couple concluding remarks so you know I
used sort of this auction design problem
it's sort of a you know excuse of sort
of scaffolding to show you all these
different interpolations of average and
worst-case analysis you know but I again
want to emphasize you know I think all
of the ideas we talked about are really
not about auction design per se or about
like algorithmic game theory per se all
of these ideas you have you know like
different ways of comparing the
performance of different solutions this
is broadly relevant for algorithms so
the reason I talk mostly about auctions
is just because there's been a larger
concentration of results of this type in
Algar in the game theory there's plenty
of analogs and mainstream algorithms but
just the density is you know the
intensity of them is bigger on the augur
in the game theory side and it
you may wonder like why would that be
okay why these kinds of results
specifically for auction and game theory
problems and if I had to speculate I'd
say you know like for the first ten
years of algorithmic game theory it
really felt like the Wild West so for
those of us that were working in the
field but we knew we didn't know what
the right models were and so we had this
kind of communal experimental phase
where we were trying out lots of
different models to see which ones led
to the most illuminating results so
everything was under question you know
including you know worst case versus
average case we should have inspired by
The Economist's and how much they had
done with average case analysis but
again you know so I think that's why
it's happened it's been so fruitful in
the algorithm theory side but I really
hope that in the years to come a lot of
these ideas you know we'll find even
deeper roots in more mainstream
algorithms so thanks very much so you
know one of the thing that many of us
have been thinking I mean you can go
back even to simplex right we should be
normally success